a documentation or vaccination is a
medical
necessity and there is a global standard
for this
you all know it it is the whos
yellow international certification
the second question is what can you use
this certificate for the use to be made
of this certificate must be very
carefully
considered there are few yet unknown
variables to take into account
for example the medical question does
vaccination inhibit transmission of the
virus by the vaccinated person
we have no answer on that and how long
is the vaccination
effective we do not know that for
certain either
and then the political question how do
you ensure that you respect the rights
of those who have not had access
to a vaccine and what other alternatives
do you offer to those
who have legitimate reasons for not
getting the vaccine
and at the same time how do we protect
the personal
data of citizen so open questions here
therefore later on when the time is ripe
we will need a thorough debate and a
consensus among member states
on possible other uses of the
certificate
you